Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
mortal kombat review for the new movie they'd also
drop the opening scene so i'll talk about that in
what's going on with this movie how it's different
from the original mortal kombat movie and how
it adapts some of the story line from the games
and what their plans are for future mortal kombat
movies so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos the movie is going
to be up pretty much everywhere later this week if
you haven't seen it already i believe it's already
dropped in a couple countries internationally
if you have seen it please don't post really huge
spoilers in the comments yet but i will explain
some of the changes they made from the original
movie because you come into a mortal kombat movie
with certain expectations for what they're going
to be doing with the story with the characters i
know there's a lot of questions about characters
that you did not see in any of the trailer footage
for the most part they are pretty authentic
to the games in the video game story really
funny detail a lot of you may not have realized
that louis tan who plays the main character cole
actually said he auditioned for the title
role of shang chi marvel just dropped their
shang chi trailer so a whole lot of martial arts
related movies coming out right now are dropping
trailers right now all of his fight scenes in
the mortal kombat movie are great but i think
the reason why he lost out on the shang chi role
is because they wanted more of a comedic spin
and he didn't really have the comedic background
that cemu liu has who comes from sitcoms
so it'll be fun to compare shang chi and the
legend of the 10 rings in the marvel universe to
mortal kombat just in terms of the way they
plot their fight scenes out mortal kombat is
a little more mma shang chi looks like it's going
to be more of a traditional kung fu type of movie
but i'll just start with the opening scene here
obviously this is meant to be the origin story of
hanzo hasashi becoming the scorpion that you know
and love from the mortal kombat video game series
and beyond the original version of sub
zero there's only one scorpion in the
video game series but there have been a couple
different people to bear the mantle of sub-zero
they don't totally cover why bihan wanted to kill
hanzo in this opening scene in his entire clan
they do actually cover that story in the later
video games it gets way more cosmic and twisty
than you would ever expect with elder gods
and titans manipulating events on this grand
cosmic scale in the mortal kombat multiverse of
realms but this first new rebooted mortal kombat
movie is mostly meant to be an origin story and
they're sort of using the scorpion character
and his family line is the introduction to
that that's why he has the opening scene here
like this is the first chapter a prequel of
sorts to the traditional mortal kombat story
of the tournament that you would normally expect
so that was probably my biggest surprise with this
movie in particular is that the tournament
is very important to the story of course
but the tournament itself doesn't happen during
this film it won't happen until the sequel movie
is all set up for the tournament like the whole
plot of this movie is mostly just world building
and origin stories for all the main characters
in a soft introduction to some of the lore and
the backstory of the story universe because like
i said it gets way more cosmic than you would ever
expect based on the original games if you only
played the original games and you haven't been
playing some of the more recent ones the story has
gotten really really deep and really crazy they've
gone full marvel cinematic universe with the
mortal kombat story i'll talk about that too as
i get deeper into my review because it does seem
like they're trying to plot this out the same way
they plot out the marvel movies the same way that
legendary with the monster verse the godzilla and
the kong movies are trying to plot their movies
out in a very marvel cinematic universe type of
way but in this first new rebooted movie you do
get a little bit of that multiverse storytelling
through the raiden character in shang tsung as
they explain the tournament of realms setting up
the sequel where earthrealm the main universe
of champions battle the champions of outworld
so that is probably the biggest difference between
this rebooted movie and the original mortal kombat
movie from the 90s in that movie they really just
do the quick character intros for all the mains
then boom you're in outworld and they're having
that first tournament they did make a sequel to
that movie called mortal kombat annihilation but i
can't stress this enough you do not have to watch
that it's a rite of passage for hardcore fans but
it is an endurance test it is not a great film
so you don't have to see it if you're not a big
super fan the other really big change from the
original movie just in terms of the way they plot
the story out is that in the original movie it's
mostly built around lou kang's story trying to
get revenge for the death of his brother then
he learns about the tournament and gets swept
up in this big fight against shang tsung in the
new movie the main character is cole lewis tan's
character and they use him as a pov character to
sort of reintroduce you to the new version of the
mortal kombat story universe but like i said it's
mostly framed through this historic war between
bihan sub-zero and his ancestor hanzo scorpion so
if you saw that mortal kombat scorpion's revenge
movie some of this movie feels a little bit like
it borrows from that storyline the plot is very
different but the energy is a little bit the same
like give me the original mortal kombat movie but
make it scorpion's revenge some of the complaints
about the movie that i've seen and i do think
that they're warranted is that the plot gets a
little out of control early on there's some pacing
issues with the way it sets up the main characters
and gets them to raiden who in the mortal kombat
story is a full-blown god tasked by the elder gods
with guiding the champions of earth realm during
each tournament's period so if you're a long time
mortal kombat fan you might be a little frustrated
with how long they take to set things up like okay
give us the tournament arc we're here for the
tournament we just want to see some fighting
there is a lot of fighting so i feel like the
one misleading thing about the trailers is that
you do see the characters fighting each other a
lot so you kind of assume that they're doing the
tournament but really like i said they're not
going to do the actual tournament to the sequel
they have a very twisty way of explaining how
they kind of have a tournament before they have
the tournament but the whole idea is that there
have been many many mortal kombat tournaments
between the realms over thousands and thousands
of years and the one that they're prepping for
in this movie for the sequel is just the most
recent version of the tournament but the movie
isn't four hours long so they only cover a little
of that history with the idea i think that they'll
dig deeper in the sequels obviously they have to
do the tournament so i think we'll get at least
one sequel it would be too weird for them to do a
whole movie just setting up the classic tournament
that everybody loves from the games and then never
actually do the proper tournament arc it would be
like them doing godzilla vs kong only just setting
up the idea that they eventually fight in a future
sequel and never actually seeing them fight they
would just piss too many people off if they did
something like that if you've been following the
video game series for a good long while the one
brand new thing the one thing that stands out
is the coal character he is not from the video
game series like i said they sort of invented him
for this movie as a pov character to reintroduce
non-mortal kombat fans to the mythology like if
you've never played the games you never saw the
original movie the story of his character is
basically meant to be the introduction to this
world there were way more characters from the
classic games than i expected i really went into
this expecting a similar roster from the first
mortal kombat movie just like the classic og
characters and yes by far the biggest thing people
commented about the biggest missing og character
was johnny cage they do have an explanation for
what's going on with him during the movie he is
referenced during the film so he does exist
within the universe and he has already been
confirmed for the sequel movie the director said
the only reason why they wanted to wait on doing
him was just because the way his personality
like his self-aggrandizing nature shifted the
tone of the story in the way his character
is written to be very attention seeking
just fits better into a classic tournament arc
which they're doing in the sequel like even though
he's not the main character of that original 1990s
film he does dominate most of the plot and one of
the other differences with this film is i think
they're trying to be a little bit more serious
with the tone like it's a hard r like really good
example that opening scene with hanzo just going
at it with all of bihan's men that's actually
pretty tame compared to some of the level of
fatalities that they get to later in the film they
take it pretty far with the fatalities like even
the actors said that they were surprised with how
graphic they got during parts of the film but like
i said if you've been following the games for a
long time you will spot all the video game moments
they are pretty faithful to the way a lot of these
things go down a lot of the fatalities like a lot
of the minor details but i know earlier i made
that godzilla versus kong reference this does feel
like a very godzilla vs kong type of film like
you go into that movie knowing exactly what kind
of movie it's going to be not expecting them to
start quoting shakespeare to each other just let
them fight let them fight so if you haven't
already seen the movie you should go into this
new mortal kombat movie with those same levels of
expectation like let them fight this is all about
them just beating the crap out of each other the
difference there though is that godzilla vs kong
is more like going to see a giant boxing match and
going to a mortal kombat movie is more like seeing
a giant mma fight just on a practical level the
mortal kombat movie was way more low budget than
i expected i think they did that so that they
could keep it hard r the fight choreography was
actually pretty solid obviously way better than
the original film special effects visual effects
have also come so far in the last 25 years since
that original film that everything just looks a
lot better they do get way crazier with a lot of
their special abilities and their powers in a way
that they did not during that original 1990s movie
but because i haven't talked about the music music
also a big deal in the mortal kombat video game
series they didn't really use the original theme
music in the trailer videos i know people were
wondering like what about the classic theme song
if you're a long time fan and you saw the original
movie you will be happy to know that they do
incorporate that classic theme music into the
movie at some point but just in general i would
say the film is okay like it's a fun time but in
the same way that godzilla vs kong has a bit of a
silly story with a lot of cool stuff that happens
during it like the actual plot itself is a little
ridiculous but the movie itself is a lot of fun so
just make sure you go into mortal kombat with that
level of expectation once you do have a chance to
see the movie just post all your reactions in the
comments below and let me know what you want them
to do with the sequels if they get multiple films
later this week after the movie comes out i will
do a full video on the ending and how they set up
the sequel and exactly what's happening i've also
got a new falcon and winter soldier dark avengers
video that i'm working on in my full falcon and
winter soldier episode 6 finale video we'll post
friday just like normal so while you wait for
everything everyone click here for my new marvel
shang chi trailer video and click here for my
falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!